netflix bought the rights for their most
watched non-english show money heist for
just two dollars the streaming service
made an incredibly smart investment one
that allowed money heist to bring more
impressive production values than the
creators could have imagined success
didn't come without its issues though
sometimes fans swarmed the set and
halted filming while other days intense
weather either ruined the set and props
or caused the actors to nearly
over the course of the series a whopping
300 different locations were used to
film that's not all though the cast and
crew were regularly crossing borders
since they shot scenes in seven
different countries denmark thailand
panama italy portugal and the uk
the show obviously has a massive
following and some of the fans wanted to
get even closer to the action one
particularly hectic day saw 4 000 fans
show up and watch the filming silently
pedro alonso and alvaro morte decided to
thank the fans for being so wonderful
but with 4 000 people wanting to say
hello filming wound up having to be
halted
[Music]
filming this scene that's meant to take
place in the chilly north atlantic
oceans was actually shot in thailand
under extreme heat conditions up to 44
degrees the actors seriously struggled
alvaro morte had to be fanned by crew
members on set to prevent him from
fainting and controlling the amount of
sweat coming through his clothing at
least when the actors were rehearsing
they were able to strip down and work
somewhat comfortably
things got a little too real for the
arturo actor when he was being treated
after being shot in the chest the team
decided they wanted the actor to undergo
actual stitches so a real surgeon was
brought to the set to perform the task
for the cameras cast and crew the cast
was very squirmy watching and were
fighting laughter throughout the scene
because of how crazy the whole situation
was
the original budget for the show was
pretty minimal compared to the later
seasons while they did eventually end up
filming around the world the team didn't
leave spain for the first two seasons
once netflix invested the whole
production got major upgrades including
access to expensive features like
private islands remarkable buildings and
helicopters cast knew they were really
gaining success when their social media
following jumped into the thousands
netflix definitely made a good
investment they didn't do any
advertising and had minimal costs to add
translations and do some restructuring
on the show
the money showering in the streets of
spain scene looked amazing but the road
to achieving that product was a long and
frustrating one the money wouldn't fly
in the right direction because of the
wind and the weather was erratic
raining one minute and getting sunny
again shortly after the rain was what
really held them back
hundreds of extras were soaked without
anywhere to get shelter the paper bills
were wet and the set became ruined
needing to get the shot the team started
to improvise the paper money was dried
with giant fans the tools used to
collect the bills normally became dryers
for the ground
eventually they nailed it
the show can be awfully serious with
such high stakes but that didn't stop
the cast from having a lot of laughs on
set although not all of them wanted
people to know just how much they could
crack up
whether they were getting a bit over
dramatic with their line delivery
or interacting with the nature around
them when they were filming on location
the cast and crew enjoyed and made the
most out of the production
wearing glasses didn't help alvaro morte
at all while he was performing it was a
hindrance more than anything since the
actor actually has 20 20 vision he
wasn't the biggest fan of the prop
glasses but eventually got used to it
since it's such a signature part of the
look as for his nickname being the
professor and not a city the fact is he
actually does have a secret city
nickname vatican city reflecting just
how protected and mysterious his
character was
all that fake money flying around of
course couldn't be real for the shots
when we see the money stacked and
scattering the streets a million 50 euro
bills were printed using machines to
print newspapers and 6 000 golden bars
were created by the props department the
bars were actually made out of bronze
and the crew was even taught how to melt
it down into tiny nuggets but they left
the actual task to the professionals for
safety reasons of course
money heist didn't just gather loads of
fans many celebrities loved the show
including aladdin actor mina masood and
mindy kaling another famous fan went so
far as to ask to be part of it
soccer player neymar jr loved the series
so much he got in touch with the team
behind the show when the third season
came around the team found a role for
the football star he was the one who
played this brazilian monk
celestial
belachow has become such a powerful song
a group of immigrants rescued from a
boat saying it when they were safe and
on land while we heard it plenty in the
show it made more contributions than we
thought the season 3 opening includes a
shot of this doorway and above it we see
una matina misono alsato that line is
what starts off the song as well
the fact that the italian folk song
became an essential part of the series
was purely by chance the tune wound up
on a mix to inspire executive producer
and head writer javier gomez santander
while he was writing when thinking about
the right song to use in the celebratory
scenes santander heard it and knew it
was the right choice
it's hard to believe now but we could
have had a different actor portraying
the professor on screen javier gutierrez
was originally offered the complex part
but it conflicted with another project
the offer didn't go straight to morte
afterwards though the team saw him five
times over the course of two months
before finally making the offer as it
turns out we could have had alvaro morte
as the narrator of the series as well
ultimately though the team realized that
having the professor is the primary
voice we hear could come off as
narcissistic and affect how audiences
felt about the character tokyo seemed
like the perfect option to narrate
especially since onscreen the men
dominate
if you were trying to rob the bank of
spain the golden vault would actually
flood
loads of research was done to prepare
for the scene the team even brought a
marine engineer into the fold so they
could properly create the chamber it
turns out the thrill of seeing the
robberies in the series did inspire some
people to actually try their hand at
similar crimes some people who committed
these real-life crimes credited the show
as their source of inspiration going so
far as to wear the red jumpsuit and
salvador dali masks
yikes
alvaro morte and pedro alonso had
amazing chemistry on and off screen
together that relationship is all them
their characters berlin and the
professor weren't actually written to be
brothers it was the actors who thought
up the whole backstory including them
both being able to speak russian since
berlin went to russia with the professor
to get medical treatment years earlier
while some actors went through an
arduous audition process to win their
roles we're looking at you alvaro others
had straight offers for parts that were
literally written for them the character
albaflores plays nairobi didn't actually
exist in the first draft of the script
after revising the writing the team
wanted another woman playing a central
role and since alex pina had worked with
alba flores before he felt she would
make a perfect addition to the cast
thankfully flores accepted the offer and
brought nairobi to the screen for the
whole series
the unlikely success of money heist goes
to show just how great a series can be
if given the chance the production's
commitment to bringing authentic
storytelling to the screen including the
real stitches and hiring of specialists
to help bring accuracy to the bank vault
is impressive and a definite reason that
we love this series so much